US president has arrived in India a
lavish spectacle a world watching the US
president's visit to India a lot of the
news coming out of India has revolved
around Trump's visit but I know that
there's a lot more going on in India at
the moment can you tell us what's
happening in Delhi right now Delhi isn't
a state I would say of uneasy tension we
saw a really gruesome 72-hour period of
violence that broke out between Hindus
and Muslims in the northeastern part of
Delhi cars burning Maus being torn down
people being killed and beaten up
helping with stones and so on around 40
people were killed in Delhi and hundreds
were injured it is true that there was
Muslim LED violence but when you step
back and look at who bore the brunt it
was the Muslim community why is this
happening what's what sparked the
situation since the Modi government came
back to power in May of 2019 it has
moved with the real sense of urgency and
a kind of clarity of purpose towards
enacting a kind of Pro Hindu agenda the
most recent thing is done is enacted
this citizenship amendment bill so what
the bill does is it provides expedited
citizenship to illegal migrants who land
up in India from one of three
neighboring countries Afghanistan
Bangladesh and Pakistan if those people
belong to essentially any religious
community other than Islam immediately
we saw protests in the streets primarily
for Muslims so why is this bill so
controversial this was seen as actually
a prelude to an even larger initiative
to create a national register of Indian
citizens
many Indian citizens whose families have
lived there for generations they don't
actually have the documents to help them
prove their citizenship so you can
imagine a scenario where both Hindus and
Muslims cannot prove their citizenship
but Hindus will be given a kind of
lifeline through the citizenship
Amendment Act because they can be given
amnesty essentially we're Muslims
because they're specifically denied
expedited citizenship under the law
would have no other recourse and this
raises a question if there is a process
to figure out who is a legitimate
resident and who's not what do you do
with the people who are not what do you
do with the people who are deemed
illegal tens of thousands scoot up
across the sand to check if they're
Indians or not detention centers for
illegal citizens India's first detention
center in Assam many more are planned
there have been detention camps built in
Assam it is a pilot project in the sense
the protests began first at primarily
Muslim colleges and universities in and
around Delhi but then they quickly
spread all around the country where you
saw in some cases hundreds of thousands
of people saying this new law is
antithetical to the liberal secular
democratic spirit of the Constitution
and some of the Hindu majority sections
in Delhi were a growing increasingly
outraged with the severity of the
protests they really use the fact of
these protests to fuel counter protests
you have legislators who are sort of
using their bully pulpit to kind of fan
these flames the rights that we've seen
in recent days have been restricted to
Delhi
the real worry is that what we saw in
Delhi is potentially the harbinger of
what could happen on a larger scale in
other parts of the country once the the
violence broke out in Delhi how was it
addressed it took about 72 hours for the
police to essentially flood the streets
with enough manpower
restore orders and the lingering
question is why it took so long if this
was such a brazen display of violence
why did the police do anything about it
and in fact their video and photographic
evidence suggests that in any case
please I don't look the other way or aid
in the beddit the mozz
Prime Minister Modi was very slow in
issuing a statement about the violence
this was during the tail-end u.s.
President Donald Trump's visit to India
a state visit you would see the
president a meeting Prime Minister Modi
and that you would see parts of Delhi
going up in flames he could have spoken
sooner to try to cool the tensions she
people that are out in the streets
protesting what is it that they want to
achieve with these protests they want to
see essentially the government repudiate
or repeal this new bill or amend it so
that it does not by omission single out
Muslims that's number one I think number
two is they want some kind of credible
commitment that this is not a prelude to
a all India citizens registry what has
created so much uncertainty and so much
angst is that no one knows what the
endgame actually is if they actually go
through this process and they find
people who are illegals that question
mark is why you see so much anxiety
right now in India
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]